it's official halos arbiter it's coming  to killer instinct Microsoft published a  gameplay trailer today which shows up a  bunch of arbiters moves any of which  make use of the characters energy sword  you can check out the full gameplay clip  in a story on gamespot for some  inspiring narration and an awful lot of  hacking and slashing arbiter will be  available as part of killer instincts  third season which is due to launch in  March the character was originally  teased during the killer instinct World  Cup at park south in January season 3  will also bring returning martial artist  Kim were to the roster and it'll  introduce a bunch of character tweaks  and rebalances let me know in that  comment section how you feel about the  addition of arbiter and stay tuned to  gamespot for all the latest on killer  instinct